hasta la invasión rusa el 24 de febrero
la capital kiev tenía tres millones
trescientos mil habitantes según las
autoridades dos terceras partes de la
población ha regresado la mayoría los
comercios están abiertos la vida es
bastante activa pero todo esto está
amenazado por los ataques realizados por
Rusia a la infraestructura eléctrica
estamos reparando estos transformadores
que alimentan las zonas alrededor esto
significa guarderías edificios
estaciones de agua el punto de calor el
resultado del ataque de la semana pasada
es que no hubo electricidad no hubo
ninguna clase de conexión en las
comunicaciones fue muy duro entender En
dónde estaba el daño y al mismo tiempo
coordinar el arreglo entre los equipos
la vida de estos técnicos e ingenieros
quedó trastocada que comenzaron los
ataques a la infraestructura eléctrica
del país Ellos dicen que muchas veces
trabajan durante 24 horas seguidas
es una gran presión psicológica porque
en el momento en que atacan entendemos
que tenemos que empezar a reparar pero
también debemos protegernos para no ser
alcanzados
todo es muy difícil nuestra construcción
es muy alta cuando se va la luz no
tenemos nada no hay elevador no hay agua
ni calefacción Si se quiere calentar
agua para dar de comer a los niños es
imposible hay que tener termos
por aquí
Hoy es un día afortunado Porque ha
salido el sol en kiefa diferencia de las
últimas jornadas en las que ha estado
nevando y estas circunstancias son
especialmente difíciles en complejo
residenciales como estos que según la
empresa de energía privada que les
provee de Electricidad solamente reciben
8 horas de energía al divididas en dos
bloques con grandes cortes en el
intermedio y ellos piensan que podría
llegar a ser peor la situación en la
medida que avanza el invierno y haya
mayor consumo de electricidad en todas
estas casas